just start if you have a good idea
there's nothing holding you back except
for yourself if you're starting all over
from scratch today what do you think the
path to like Fame and money is uh for a
comedian the first thing I think anyone
needs to have is confidence rejection is
a good thing every person that says no
or an opportunity that doesn't work gets
you closer to that goal I live my life
that way Humanity needs to band together
and like not let the government or the
media dictate who they can like and who
they cannot like if we don't fix that
we're in trouble all right guys bang
bang I've got Madison here uh I think
one of the common themes of a ton of
people I've talked to is it's people who
just like bet on themselves kind of pave
their own path in the world which I know
that you've done multiple times
um when you think of that specific thing
people who are watching or listening to
this uh it really resonates with them
they're like oh I want to be able to do
that but I'm scared or like what if it
doesn't work or like what are the 27
steps that I need to write out and make
sure that like my mom dad brother sister
everyone signs off on before I go do it
it doesn't seem like you did any of that
it seems like you kind of just like
jumped one day like how do you think
about Paving your path in a different
way uh in kind of like internet age well
I The Internet's been great obviously
there's some downfalls of the internet
but the internet's amazing
people with so much opportunity that
they probably wouldn't have had and I
feel like now if you want to be famous
or be a content creator or be a brand
ambassador like you can you can pretty
much do anything you want to but you
have to believe in yourself first so
obviously it's just starting a lot of
people don't start businesses because
they look at Step A to Z and they go
there's just so much to do I'm so
overwhelmed I'm never gonna do this how
about you just do a b and c and then you
move on to the next ones and so it's
always like just start if you have a
good idea don't sometimes you don't want
to tell people about it because you just
don't want the energy around it but I
think it's like if you believe in it
there's nothing holding you back except
for yourself yeah uh you mentioned if
you want to be famous on the internet do
you think most Comedians and people who
like try to go do uh the intersection of
content touring you know audience
building like whatever this uh way you
want to describe it is that the ultimate
goal is like be famous is it like a
performance how did you think about it
when you first started like what drove
you to actually want to go do this well
Fame and money are are they kind of go
hand in hand yeah or at least you think
they go hand in hand when you start yeah
so you you want to be famous or else you
wouldn't be putting yourself out there
and you wouldn't be like when I started
comedy did I think that this road would
be so long and that it would take me in
so many different directions absolutely
not I would have never started really
never sorry if somebody told me you're
gonna start comedy you're gonna have
some uh you know little successes along
the way you're going to meet a lot of
great people but you're not really going
to have any like Financial
windfalls for over 10 years or 12 years
I would have said I'm out is that a
better way to do it though right like
would you have rather the first time you
go up on stage it's a hit there's like
an agent in the crowd and they're like
bam I found the next absolute Savage
they're gonna be the most famous
comedian ever here's like a 100 million
dollar deal or would you rather like a
miracle
actually I think it's called a fantasy I
don't think that's ever happened in the
history of all of comedians but like I
kind of feel like when you talk to
comedians like part of the thing that
they enjoy the most or that they respect
is that like anybody who's reached any
level of success is like been on the
grind a little bit
Yeah a hundred percent the stuff you
have to do the the events you sacrifice
the dating
your time with friends missing weddings
there's so much you sacrifice for to get
paid hardly anything to try to like
become the next big thing and entertain
these people you have to love it or else
you're gonna jump off a bridge because
it is a very depressing road if you
don't love it so if you are starting all
over from scratch today what do you
think the path to like Fame and money is
uh for a comedian right the internet's
here we have all these different people
who have done so many different things
like what is the path in your mind today
where it's like all right this is the
Playbook the first thing I think anyone
needs to have is confidence if you do
not have confidence your road is just
going to be a lot longer because if you
don't have it you're going to be
hesitant to put out the content you need
to get discovered you're going to
question everything you're not going to
take the risk that you need to be on
stage so it's definitely like the
confidence and then the confidence will
equal
being able to create more content
because you believe in yourself so you
think content on the internet is really
the key even more so than touring or
anything else it's like how do you just
create content now maybe touring feeds
into that uh or whatever but it's like
if you have confidence and you can
create tons of content and you're
actually whole you know funny hilarious
whatever then you got a shot yeah yeah
that's it it's just it's just a Content
game yeah it's amazing what somebody can
do with a fan base like I've watched
Comics that have that are recently
they're kind of new and but they had a
big following on social media and they
wanted to do comedy and they're very
successful and because they have the big
following they can fill up the theaters
and you could be the best comic or the
worst comic and you can still book a
theater as long as you can fill the
seats the booker isn't looking oh are
you are you good enough for this do you
meet our criteria they're looking to put
asses in the seats yeah and if you can
meet that with a huge following guess
what you're gonna make a lot of money
walk me through just high level
economics right so uh I'm a comedian I
start out uh I've got a good enough
following I'm going to a city uh where
I've got a pretty good base in that city
am I trying to sell 50 tickets 500
tickets like early in my career what is
like the size of the audiences that uh
people are having to sell and then what
does that actually translate in terms of
uh maybe the ticket price and then how
much does the comment get versus the
venue or whatever so it kind of depends
on the venue but the experiences that
I've had is when you're you're on the
road and you're doing some of these
clubs you know you want to sell between
two to four to five hundred okay
depending on what the club will kind of
seat but if you're an independent artist
or an independent producer so to say for
the show
um some clubs will they'll give you 80
at the door oh wow so if you can sell
that out and you're charging 20 or 25
bucks a ticket and you're taking home 80
percent
you had a pretty good weekend yeah a
couple thousand bucks right out of the
gate and for you know a night's worth of
work no I did a Wednesday I remember in
Denver and I had that deal at the Denver
Improv okay and I got all my friends to
come out and it was amazing we sold the
thing out there's 350 people there and I
received the check that night and the
next day I was on the table getting
LASIK
in cash
what oh yeah so wait a second your
friends paid for your Lasik surgery
I told some big jokes and now I've got
20 20 Vision yeah that's perfect the the
part of this that just I'm so fascinated
by is like the internet created all of
these different tools and some people
have used the tools amazingly well some
people even use them to become president
of the United States right like
literally uh anything is possible on the
internet now but the other part of it is
it's not just the content creation it's
the monetization as well like so you're
talking about hey if you're able to get
yourself in a position where you're uh
kind of a producer of the event you can
get 80
someone somewhere along the way taught
you that or told you hey you can do this
versus the comic who just is like oh
yeah I'll come and you know a couple
hundred bucks or whatever and I'll just
perform so like how do you think over
the last decade or so the business of
this entire industry changed is it just
that like enough uh comedians tried in
enough things to eventually put
themselves in a position where they
understood or is it no technology
changed and so now people can do
different things like like what change
that allowed you to do stuff like that
like necessarily
so what happens is when you start at
being a comic you need to get stage time
and so a lot of your gigs are unpaid and
so a great way to build relationships
and get stage time is to produce your
own shows whether it's at a bar or a
smaller room in a club as long as you
can fill the seats the clubs don't care
so it's a money game and so like you
would do that and then you would learn
like okay it's usually like a door deal
which is great I remember I did one show
one time I was doing like a temp job
just to pay my bills when I was slinging
as a comedian and I invited the whole
office and the the guy said listen the
owner of the club said I just want the
drinks if you can pack this place out
I'm gonna give you 100 at the door
really I got 90 people to show up from
that office
I made more that night than I did like
working 40 hours a week for two weeks
yeah I mean it was great it's pretty
incredible how uh much of life is in
negotiation like in in other countries
you literally can go to uh a certain
store and like you can negotiate the
price in America maybe not as much
um but but like there are many things in
life where uh if you are entrepreneurial
and you have that skill set and you
enjoy negotiating right which some
people don't but if you do enjoy that
like you can really put yourself in a
position to be successful for simply
producing if you're willing to bet on
yourself oh absolutely I mean if you
took two people and you you measured
their confidence level and you took the
one that was more confident and you said
okay you guys are given the same task
you're going to go into the same club
and you're gonna get yourself booked and
you guys have the same amount of people
that you think can come in you can sell
out the show who's gonna get the better
deal the one with the more confidence
because you believe in yourself how did
you get so much I didn't always have
confidence okay I actually people were
shocked by that a lot because I came off
very confident
um but I was heavily insecure and I
think it made my path in comedy longer
because I was afraid I literally lived
in fear of What Fear I just anxiety of
like what's gonna happen what are they
gonna think
um what if I do bad and then my friends
come and they think I'm a loser what are
people gonna think of me and finally
when I was able to kind of with that
through a lot of kind of like inner work
and then listening to a lot of like
self-help podcasts and just kind of
realized I think it was honestly I I
came across a near-death experience
video and I'm fascinated by these wait
what okay like so people have you seen
these videos what is the video so if you
just type in near-death experience
there's going to be tons of them so
they're people that have died you
realize that's a weird thing to search
for on the internet well it came across
like on my feet I feel like it was like
fate okay all right so now I'm like oh
this is great so there's all these
people that have died they cross over
they either see their relatives or they
meet Jesus or God and they come back and
they're completely changed because
everything is put into perspective okay
and so I was so fascinated by this that
I started watching more okay and then it
came out that there was like a Life
review right and they're basically uh
these are people talking about the
experience of basically dying and coming
back yeah okay and just like how amazing
it was up there and how how how we have
a mission here and we have a purpose and
my purpose wasn't done so I had to come
back and what they all came back and
said is that I have no more fear I have
no fear of what people think I have no
fear of dying I have we aren't designed
to be fearful our society promotes fear
and obviously the media promotes fear
because they need to keep you tuned in
and control so the fear so that was a
video where I thought you know it kind
of put into perspective wow I could die
at any moment any of us could be gone do
I Want My Life review that some of these
people talked about to be showing oh
this is where you were too scared to do
this this is where you didn't believe in
yourself to do this this is what you
could have been had you not been so
fearful and lacked confidence it's the
Bezos regret minimization right where
basically when you're 80 years old and
you look back on your life how do you uh
make decisions today so that when you do
that look back you have as few regrets
as possible and if you can do that
successfully you probably live a pretty
good life you live a great life because
at the end of the day like think about
it people worry about what people think
and that will keep you stuck in whatever
situation that you're in but when you
when somebody passes you on the street
and they're wearing like a stupid outfit
and maybe you judge them
based on it for a quick second
two minutes later you've already moved
on with your day you're not even
thinking about them so people need to
realize like people will judge you but
they're really not that concerned about
you they're concerned about themselves
so don't be fearful of what they think
because it doesn't matter this is like
the troll problem on the Internet is uh
uh almost never do you see someone who's
highly successful
punching down talking [ __ ] trolling
other people it's always the people who
are insecure depressed upset uh have
some issue in their life and you you
should feel bad like like it is actually
sad that that gives them some sort of
release or or uh enjoyment in their life
but could you imagine if Jeff Bezos or
uh Elon Musk or whoever was on the
internet all day and like talking [ __ ]
to you know avatars like just random
people or whatever like you just don't
see it that often right yes there are
exceptions but you don't see that often
and I think a huge piece of it is
because those people are more focused on
like what they're doing than on you know
how do I tear down other people maybe I
don't know yeah well I think the key to
happiness is to focus focus on what
you're doing don't worry about other
people you know but I always say like
somebody asked me an interesting
question
can you cuss on this podcast do whatever
the [ __ ] you want okay good okay just
just checking I'm like you did bring me
on I've got [ __ ] my book title
um and then I just had a brain fart I
don't remember somebody asked you a
question a really interesting question
and then you asked me if you could curse
on the podcast
[Laughter]
thought just totally escaped escaped can
I come back can I go back to once one
thing on the near death uh experience
there's supposedly like some kind of uh
uh doctor or like person who uh uh helps
people who've gone through this
experience uh uh planner was recently
telling me that she's like there's this
guy and that's all he does is he like
talks to the people who died and then
came back or whatever and he's
supposedly like laser focused on like
this shit's real
yeah oh 100 I mean I 100 obviously
believe in the afterlife okay and but
like what's there
I didn't think we're gonna have this
heavy conversation today but like so uh
I'm gonna give you two data points and
then you tell me what you think the
afterlife's like uh I saw I'm gonna call
it a meme I don't think it was meant to
be a meme I think it was more of like a
a nice uh uh image that's supposed to
speak very uh deeply to your your senses
if I call those memes
um and it was uh two babies in a womb
and they were like talking to each other
and they were like oh man uh there's
nothing after this like you know oh this
is like cool life right now you know no
don't go towards the light you know
whatever and then like it's like then
they're born they get into the whole
world and so the whole idea is like it
just is the second version is like us
saying that on uh you know on Earth and
then eventually there's some afterlife
but then the second thing is uh there's
like the science community and the
science Community will hit you with the
like there is no evidence
so how do you settle those two things of
uh what I'll call belief religion you
know whatever versus like the science
piece well there are some scientists
that have actually
well first of all enter
and we're energy so therefore we can't
die so and if you look at like the
universe and the Law of Attraction you
get on that hole we're a collective
conscious right so your thoughts are
creating your energy or creating
everything now for me being religious
it's like work we come here to have a
human experience when we actually belong
up there
so I think it's it's from what I've
heard from people as well but it's just
this amazing
uh life where there's no pain no
fighting just peace just chilling
reconnected with your loved ones which
makes it even funnier when people are
like I got to the gates and they were
like nah go back you're not done yet
right like like damn they didn't let you
in like I guess I always think is like
uh to some degree getting saying I had
didn't fulfill my purpose yet is also a
way to say like I got rejected I know
right well it's like you can't come yet
so yeah you may get up you may get in
later but like right now you're not
allowed in yeah
so but that should wake enough people up
to where it's like okay so I do have a
purpose all of us are giving gifts and
given purposes it's our job to then tap
into those and find out what they are to
be able to when we do die that we
actually get let in so there's a a movie
uh Coach Carter uh Samuel L Jackson I
think is uh he plays Coach Carter and uh
and he keeps asking uh uh the players
like what are you scared of what are you
scared of and what he's essentially
trying to get them to do is is recite
the famous uh poem quote whatever uh
like we basically fear ourselves right
like we fear what we're actually capable
of accomplishing and uh I think there's
a lot of people who will listen to this
podcast other podcasts who they're like
uh uh droning right I call it uh droning
they're just going through their day and
they're kind of just going through the
motions because that's what they think
they're supposed to do and the only time
that they kind of get shaken with
reality is a near-death experience is uh
something catastrophic uh somebody gets
hurt something happens the life that
kind of shakes them and wakes them up
but you kind of look at this and you're
like man there's a large portion of the
population that are just droning and so
how do you think like 100 you can get
those people out of kind of just doing
what they've always done and they wake
up you know 40 years later like oh [ __ ]
where'd my life go yeah well I'll share
a quick story about I didn't realize I
was I drowned for a long time oh you're
a droner I used to not anymore but I
used to and I remember I would wake up
and I would be like you know kind of
tired I didn't have the energy it wasn't
motivated and I just felt like ah
another day and I would just go through
the motions and you know I was like oh
another day till closer to death another
day closer to death you say to yourself
what the heck right and it was a wake-up
call going what am I do like this is
insane like if this is life this
something has to change and then I'd go
away for weekends and then I'd get super
sad when I'd have to come back on Sunday
and it was a wake-up call Sunday scary
something had to change in my life why
were you sad on Sundays when you came
back because I didn't like the life I
was living uh so it was like uh escapism
about it yeah the weekends were an
escape and then you had to come back to
reality yeah it was like I was living
for that for the future I wasn't
enjoying my life I wasn't and enjoying
the days I was waiting until I somebody
discovered me I was waiting until I got
rich I was waiting for all these things
instead of actually enjoying the moment
which is the present and once I I
finally said okay this isn't gonna work
I need to enjoy my life I have so much
to be grateful for I'm getting rid of
the fear I'm gonna work on my confidence
and that is where the magic started to
happen and now I'm excited I love
Sundays I get football during fall and
then I get to wake up and I'm like you
know what I like the weekdays better
because I get closer to all my goals so
one of my favorite questions to ask uh
people is if I gave you a hundred
million dollars what would you do in the
weeks afterwards right like like
basically money is no longer a problem
yeah what would you do what would you do
with your life and uh there's two
answers that I find uh uh both equally
fascinating one the people who are
honest are like I try to get to 200
million
right there like like they understand
human psychology of like no matter how
much you have you always want something
more so like I appreciate the
self-awareness and just the brutal
honesty but what most people say is I
would do x and x is like a dream uh uh
something that they they don't think is
possible whatever and I always ask them
like why don't you go do that today yeah
or or start doing that now
and it's fascinating how many people are
like I never thought of that
you're just like I know again I don't
have any answers like I'm not by no
means any different than anybody else
I'm a human I do dumb [ __ ] all the time
I I drone I do all this stuff
not really drone but like you know I'm a
a human like everyone else
but to not like just sit down and be
like what do I want to do seems like we
are almost as a society selling
ourselves short because there's no
intentionality about our actions we kind
of are just droning along well no and
it's true but I think also what happens
with the droning is that people are so
afraid and worried about what other
people will think that they don't take
the risk and they stay in that drone
because when they're droning and just
going to their job coming home doing
their errands doing what they're
supposed to be doing nobody's really
judging them or worrying about them but
it kind of comes down to that too isn't
cubicle life more of a risk than doing
something else like my greatest 100 my
greatest fear in life is to uh have been
you know 25 30 years old uh go to work
every day maybe now in most of the big
corporations you don't have to wear the
tie but you got to have you know kind of
uh dressed up with button down on
everything yeah and then just like go to
sleep one night wake up you're 55 you
got three kids and you're like yo
where'd it go what happened I don't
remember and then you get laid off well
just even like that's even taking it to
the extreme like if you just literally
worked the same job for 30 years and
then you wake up one day and you're like
holy [ __ ] I just spent 30 years doing
this and like what happened that that to
me again people have all these you know
uh weird uh uh risks or scared of or
fears whatever right that's mine I would
go [ __ ] insane and then probably do
crazy [ __ ] to like make up for it and
like end up dying somehow right like
yeah but but it just feels like that is
actually the normal path that a lot of
people take
it's safety for them it's an illusion
now it's their illusion of safety but I
think it's also because people are
afraid to put themselves out there all
right so or they want a simple simple
life you wrote this book time to lighten
the [ __ ] up a self-help guide uh with a
side of humor if you didn't write this
book I wouldn't ever read it because it
says self-help guy and I'd be like this
is [ __ ] but it's actually funny
right and uh you talk about things that
I think are
um the taboo topics like it's like a
like a a blunt truth and one of them is
this idea of tunnel vision
which if I say Focus people like oh
that's a good thing
the way you describe tunnel vision is
not necessarily a good thing so talk a
little bit about this idea of like
tunnel vision and like why so many
people get kind of the blinders and and
maybe it actually ends up hurting them
more than it helps in their life well
because so they get fixated on one thing
right maybe they went to college for
finance and then they get a job on Wall
Street and they're working and they're
going down the path and then 10 12 15
years later
they're miserable but they're like this
is all I can do this is the goal the
goal was Wall Street this is it so
they're stuck in that Tunnel right so
any other opportunities that will come
their way they're not going to see them
because they've got the blinders on
because they're stuck in this like
tunnel but then you have other people
too who said I'm gonna follow my dream
and they pick that dream whether it's a
stand-up comedian or an actress and they
say I'm never giving up on my dreams I'm
gonna follow this dream and
chances are you might not ever make it
because it's a very difficult path to go
down so they're just struggling
financially their whole life hoping to
make it some get really lucky and make
it some don't but they're stuck in this
tunnel I have to do this this is my end
goal or they start a company that's not
working out and they stay in it longer
because they're stuck in that tunnel
tunnel vision is not good okay I think
it's always important to have a dream
whether it's Finance whether it's
entrepreneurship whatever it is but
always be aware of the other
opportunities that can come out of
having that goal my goal when I started
was to be a comedian and then to be an
actress so I could help fill the seats
of my show now had I had tunnel vision I
might still be struggling and unhappy
but I decided to kind of look at the
business say you know what I love
entertaining I love writing I love
inspiring people there's so much more I
can do so when I stepped out of the
tunnel I fell into producing and I was
really good at creating Concepts and
bringing teams together to do it and all
of a sudden I would you know I was
struggling getting auditions now I was
sitting in front of some of the biggest
CEOs in Hollywood
talking about what I had created and
that they were actually excited about it
because also I was a finance major I
came to them with ideas not this is my
passion and I love this they don't give
a [ __ ] I came at it where this is where
we can make money and this is why I
think it's going to be profitable but I
was able to open that that tunnel and
I'm still an entertainment I still
consider myself an Entertainer but I'm
not stuck waiting for somebody to
validate me now I've got a book I've
create television shows I run side
business I do whatever I can to make
money because Financial Freedom
will set you free in anything you do so
I don't think I've ever talked about
this publicly but I have a theory on
what is happening in the internet age uh
and almost everybody I see publicly
commenting on it seems to misunderstand
what you're saying which is uh there's a
term Creator it was like oh Creator
Creator Creator and I get what they're
trying to articulate in that
but to me there is a rise of winners or
rise of just entrepreneurs yeah it's not
a rise of creators these people are not
creators they are the equivalent of the
mainstream or the Main Street small
business 20 30 years ago so people would
go to high school they'd get out maybe
go to college maybe they didn't and then
if they wanted to create economic
independence or economic uh uh kind of
uh um uh kind of bet on themselves and
get that economic uh stability what they
would do is they would look around like
how do I create a business it was all in
the analog world so they would literally
go and open up a storefront they would
sell something they would create a
service they would come to your house
whatever they would do but it was like a
Main Street small or medium-sized
business the really successful ones
could go from a town to a city maybe to
a region and if you were really really
successful you could scale it nationally
yeah right now what we're seeing is
people were like why would I ever have
an asset heavy business where I need a
store instead I can set up a Shopify
page or I can create content on the
Internet or I can do all these different
things in the digital age but they're
not creators they are absolutely just
entrepreneurs and I I use the term
winner because you you just said it no
matter what I set out to do I'm gonna
find a way to be successful at doing
this I can create money so I can be free
well exactly and there's so many like
Amazon you mentioned Shopify there's
Amazon stores you can do very little
risk and you can see how it goes and
then you can kind of scale the risk
right so you're not get you don't have
to you know take a year-long lease and
then if it doesn't work out you're stuck
with this lease you can actually set up
a store where you're not paying a lease
and then just buy the product so there's
so many like easier ways to do things I
mean it's crazy I I'm not going to
mention the name but like I just heard
that there was a comic who has an only
fans page who's making it you have to
say the name who is it upwards well I
heard it on the but when I was doing the
Bennington show think her name's Carrie
Feehan feehand great comic okay she's
got an only fans Paige and she's making
upwards of 40 Grand a month just on the
only fans page and that is it like and
I'm going is she uploading am I the
stupid one here because I don't have an
only fans page but is she uploading
comedy content is she uploading like
nude photos like what she's got it she's
got a great great body got it so uh uh
she is selling access uh or views I
guess is uh I never really thought of
the only fans uh from the
individual uploading the photos
depending on what you're uploading like
there's a lot of skewed risk reward
right it almost feels like like somebody
said to me hey uh pump if you upload
pictures of your knees every day and
you'll make a bunch of money doing it
let me let me think about this for a
second right but now if they were like
hey Pop you gotta upload a bunch of
naked photos of yourself I think I'm out
like I just not my thing yeah you're out
right and so it does feel like uh when
people hear only fans in some way this
idea of a paywall is the same thing like
we're seeing paywalled newsletters we're
seeing paywall podcasts we're seeing
paywalled what's essentially just
Instagram right like photos videos
whatever uh then we have the paywalls of
the mainstream media like like it does
feel like people are realizing if you
put up a paywall and put value behind it
that people want
somebody somewhere is going to pay for
Value yeah and then you just got to
decide what is the value you want to
provide behind that paywall today's
episode is brought to you by Exodus you
can use exodus to buy crypto for zero
fees for a limited time they just
launched a brand new wallet that allows
you to use one wallet across all the
different networks ethereum Solana
polygon or whatever else you want to use
if you go to exodus.com pump you can go
ahead and use that wallet or you can buy
Bitcoin ethereum or any other crypto
asset you can use your bank account your
credit card Apple pay or Google pay
Exodus is here for you head on over to
exodus.com pump today to get started
exodus.com pump they support us you go
support them well exactly like I never
did only fans
um I I thought about it my dad actually
had a client
um who did very well obviously he can't
share that information
uh but I said why are you telling me
this he goes hey we don't judge I'm
sorry you're trying to tell me to start
an only fan space she goes
this girl might have made more than my
doctor clients I was like what yeah it
was insane so but here's the thing there
I there's a friend of mine who runs like
a very raunchy podcast and I go on once
in a blue moon and she has these porn
stars and they are pulling up to the
studio in like huge Range Rovers and
they've got nice Chanel bags and all
this I mean they could be broke because
they're spending it all on liabilities
but they are selling pictures of their
feet
they've got only fans Pages the feed
shade cracks we have I'm sorry
I know their question and I'm sitting
here going uh buy my book and I'm like
geez I could just upload a picture of my
snatch and how much how much do they
charge for the only fans you know like
the people uploading their feet I don't
know but everyone's like why don't you
do a faceless one I think that they
should uh have a reality TV show where
they go around and they find the only
fan subscribers yeah and basically like
interview them and just be like Yo dude
you're paying 200 a month to look at
pictures of feet I know we gotta find
out the rest of your life like this
would be an interesting ass episode to
understand who you are I know everyone's
fascinated with the person uploading the
photos but like I bet you there's some
crazy stories and the people who are
paying to see feet picks on only fans
well I didn't realize that feet a feet
foot fetish of such a big thing is that
real it is real I had there was a guy
who worked as a chef in one of the
comedy clubs and I don't know which one
it was but he apparently was public
about his foot fetish and I don't have
like I don't have ugly feet I don't have
bunions or anything like that but
apparently I remember in my acting days
there was a job where I could go and
model shoes it was like 400 for the day
it was on a Saturday it was like at a
Convention Center it was like a Shoe
Show and so she goes send me a pic
picture of your foot because you're the
ideal size
and then she comes back and she goes
unfortunately you don't qualify
because your your feet don't meet the
criteria
somebody told me I have ugly feet
because apparently my second toe is
longer than my first
which my mom always told me it's because
you're a leader but I think it's just
that [ __ ] up feet is that not what
everyone's toes are no really apparently
to have beautiful feet you're everything
has to be like sloped down somebody
could tell me I was ugly somebody could
tell me that they didn't like me
whatever but it started talking [ __ ]
about my feet
hold on a second what the feet do to you
well I respond to the woman I said oh I
didn't know I didn't know that was a
thing I never saw that my feet were an
issue right but and I just wrote her
back I said well I got beautiful fake
tits if you need a bra model so call me
back you know
she's like good to know I also feel like
uh uh I'm surprised there hasn't been
more trolling of this whole like thing
so you know
I'm shocked that there hasn't been uh a
male YouTuber who's like I'm gonna start
a feet pick only only fans and like
let's see how much money we can make
because I actually think that we live in
this like meme culture where a bunch of
people would subscribe because they
think it's hilarious and then it would
end up becoming a thing and then next
thing you know everybody who's rational
and like rooted in reality would be like
what is happening how's this person
making you know 50 Grand a month uh as a
joke doing feed picks on only fans well
I agree who are the people I'll do it
I'll volunteer my feet right now see how
much we can make in a month I'm in but
it also is uh uh the experimentation I
do think kind of coming back to this
idea of people who are better on
themselves and kind of uh pave their own
path on the internet uh the
experimentation is really important
right and we were talking earlier uh
Andrew Schultz uh being able to record a
special
sell it go Direct to the people which
like there had been some other comedians
who had done it but I think there's this
like breaching of yo how real is my
audience how much do they kind of [ __ ]
with me right versus they come to the
shows okay they come out whatever are
they gonna buy a special direct where
their expectations normally it'll be on
a streaming platform
and then
yo if I release it publicly for free
afterwards am I going to offend the
people who paid for it or am I going to
offend the people who didn't pay for
like like it seems they've gone pretty
smooth yeah but that's a pretty big
experiment to run with what is a major
milestone in your career of getting a
comedy special created and so like it
feels like the people who end up being
the most successful are actually the
people willing to do the experiments in
order to figure out what works well
first thing I'll say about Andrew
Schultz he's not funny at all we're not
allowed to say that he's funny at all in
the podcast oh I think he's great but
the one thing that this guy really
really had I mean he's got so many
things I'm such I'm a fan he's confident
his confidence level's off the charts so
he's got that so he is willing to take
him damn I don't say nice things about
him
he's got because I I crossed path to
them you know in New York when we were
starting he was always such a nice
person I haven't seen him for years but
very just nice person but he's got the
confidence so he's willing he's he's
able to bet on himself because he
believes in himself and I also heard
when he you know because I follow him
when he was doing that special
originally they wanted wasn't it gonna
go to a streaming platformed it because
they wanted to censor him yeah and he
goes no these jokes are authentic this
is me I'm not censoring this this is
what my audience wants and then that's
when he pulled it I thought that was
great that is somebody who believes in
them themselves and he's a great story
of how believing in yourself will pay
off bigger than just getting a suit to
believe in you meaning the head of a
streamer the um uh there's a book
there's a crazy book uh Robert Greene
who wrote 48 Laws of Power you know a
number of great uh books and 50 Cent
wrote a book together I don't know how
much 50 contributed to the writing but
definitely the ideas are there right
Robert probably did a little bit more
the writing yeah um but this book is
actually uh fantastic I've recommended a
lot of people and they're like what do
you mean I'm not going to read a book
about Robert Greene and 50 Cent but what
it does is it takes a lot of the
concepts that Roberts talked about about
in many of his books and it takes 50
cents life and it basically overlays
them on each other and it's like man
these concepts are really really well
understood by people in hip-hop or
people on the street or whatever they
just don't talk about them using the
same uh language that Robert uses so
they in they learn the ideas they pick
them up somebody teaches them it or it's
intuitive or whatever and one of the
ideas they spent a lot of time on is 50
Cents mixtape strategy and the Mixtape
strategy is basically uh he actually had
a deal I think it was with Columbia
Records if I remember correctly and on
the night before the first major album
gets released he gets shot gets dropped
immediately from the record label
they're like there's too much violence
we can't be associated with this stuff
like like basically kick them to the uh
to the curb and they're like we're done
okay you just got shot nine times your
mouth is wired shut uh you lost your
record deal like you just went from the
night before the height of your career
up into that point to like the bottom of
your career essentially yeah and so what
he decided to do was he basically just
flooded the streets of New York with
mixtapes and including would just hand
them out would do whatever it could to
basically make people be like yo who is
this guy yeah and he essentially brute
forced the momentum to build an audience
why it's fascinating is because you just
have to do that with a CD on the streets
now it's like easy now you can just go
put music out on the internet go put on
social media whatever and if it's good
it takes off
with this concept of like he was willing
to bet on himself even after he had
reached some you know level of success
now he wasn't a mega star on a global
basis or whatever but he was forced to
go back to square ones forced to go back
to the starting point and he still ended
up being successful and I think that
that's like a common theme in a lot of
these people is like okay one road
doesn't look so great or there's a door
that gets closed or whatever what's the
next thing just keep moving forward and
that and they end up being successful
because they're willing to bet on
themselves oh absolutely and and also if
you carry that mindset like I you know
rejection is a good thing because I feel
like we're given a certain amount of
doors until we reach our our what we
consider success so every person that
says no or an opportunity that doesn't
work gets you closer to that goal I live
my life that way
and I love it because that way when
things don't work out I'm like life's
happening for me I'm now that much
closer to the door that's actually going
to happen so it's that mindset but he
had the same thing he was like okay well
it's gonna work so I just gotta figure
out a different way to do it
but
he 50 Cent obviously has extreme
confidence oh he he's he is such a long
time to get there but now that I do I
feel I feel Unstoppable in my own way
but I also feel that my driving force
behind everything I do is to help and
inspire people okay explain that more so
I feel like I have Karma on my side
and I don't do it too you think it's
real absolutely 100 why I just because I
mean honest it's well I want to say it's
just because it's what I believe but I
feel like but how did you build it like
when you were a kid did you always
believe in karma or at some point did
you like well it's like you're doing
experience or what yeah you do unto
others as you want done to yourself so
if you're a piece of [ __ ] people are
going to be a piece of [ __ ] to you I
think this is the energy that kind of
comes back to you I don't I feel like we
can't get away with with that much and
if it doesn't get you in this life maybe
it'll get you in the next if we
reincarnate I don't know but I do
believe in karma which I think is a good
thing because obviously it prevents you
from being a piece of [ __ ] I'm not a
piece of [ __ ] at all I I'm not mean I
like people I want to help people that's
my thing but there's a lot of like
obviously you know corruption because
people want to just make the money oh I
oh this is what I remembered when I said
can I oh can I guess on this podcast all
right somebody said to me I was actually
on it it was weird I was on a date like
a first date we were leaving we were at
the Four Seasons man I've been on our
first date in a long time those are
weird as [ __ ] I got it and so we're
leaving we're leaving this this place
and somebody says and he says um would
you ever [ __ ] for an opportunity
he asked you that on the first date
I don't know to respect that question or
be like you are a [ __ ] [ __ ] what
was your response I laughed because I'm
like that's hilarious because I I find
out she's being funny he wasn't being
disrespectful I'm not somebody that gets
offended I hate to get like um offended
culture yeah [ __ ] that noise are you
offended it and I said so I turned
around I gave her I gave him an answer
and I said
the only opportunity I'm [ __ ] for is
a chance to walk down the aisle with a
wedding ring okay so that's the
opportunity you're talking about then
yes I [ __ ] for opportunity you know what
I mean I mean like now and he started
laughing he goes that's a great answer
all right I was gonna say somebody who
asked that question's got one or two
reactions they get super offended or
they think anything is hilarious back so
you thought it was funny oh it's hot
yeah absolutely so he goes oh so you
just saved that guy's career by the way
because the internet sluice would have
figured out who it was and tried to
cancel him if uh if he was being an
[ __ ] oh exactly that's how the world
works now right it's like you said
something and then they go and they
figure it out and they just like pick a
random person they're like this person
yeah I know it's so it's so awful but I
have a whole chapter in here about like
being like offended like it's time to
stop being so offended I think that uh
we should actually think bring back the
right for people to offend others now
not because you should go through your
life trying to offend everybody right
you don't want to be mean it just
happens
the idea of offending someone
usually falls into one or two bucks not
every time but usually falls into one or
two buckets either you are saying
something that is true
that they don't want to hear because
they don't want to admit it to
themselves or whatever and and usually
again not always but usually in those
scenarios
you're actually helping them in some way
whether they realize it today or not
whatever 100 there's a situation
recently uh a company I'm invested in
the founder went met with a bunch of
investors they gave him some pretty
honest feedback he was very very
offended
at the beginning okay fast forward about
two months or so
he calls me up one day and he says uh
they were right
and to his credit
he went and he sent them a message and
said hey I know that when you were
saying that like it was kind of tough
like but thank you like you you didn't
have to tell me the truth you didn't
have to like you could either pay or not
interested whatever right thank you you
were right here's what I'm doing about
it and I thought it was like so mature
and just so amazing to see somebody who
did that now the other side of the
offending is like people are just
[ __ ] right and you're like literally
you're just being an [ __ ] and you
should stop doing that right but this
idea of like bringing back offending
people is
we live in a culture where now people
don't tell each other the truth
oh because they're terrified because
literally if you walk outside and you're
like the sky's red and everyone's like
yeah then you're like okay I made it
through today and nobody tried to cancel
me well I know do you realize that I
actually said a prayer last night before
I went to bed okay and this is what I
prayed I said I'm so grateful
that I get to go on pomp show I'm very
grateful to you for having me okay thank
you but I said please let me say
anything that's gonna get me canceled
there's uh there's a second piece to the
cancellation story that I have realized
recently
and maybe implicitly we all kind of sort
of knew this but now we got hard
examples of it did you see this guy Matt
Walsh
just recently so Matt Walsh he had a
great video yeah you tell it great he
just
he said a bunch of things that I think
there's a lot of people around the
country were like that makes sense
when that happens in today's society
there's also a lot of people who say
[ __ ] cancel whatever right so it was
controversial and there was a react
strong reaction uh in support and a
strong reaction uh to come after him
and he made a video and when I saw the
video first thing was damn they got him
that Walsh is gonna he's gonna take the
uh uh kind of the bow he's gonna say I'm
sorry you know I shouldn't have said
this whatever they got him
and I was watching the video and there
was no subtitles so I click open you
know I hit the volume on Twitter and
he's got this look he's staring dead
Square in the camera
and he said I will not apologize yeah
and he just took a stand he was like I'm
not apologized I'm not giving one
[ __ ] inch to the Mob exactly and I
was like holy [ __ ] that guy just became
uncancible well and he said because he
said I'm not apologizing like I believe
what I believe and I still think you
guys are wrong well it and it's
brilliant because he stands firm in his
beliefs but he also said they can't
cancel you if you don't agree to be you
have to agree to it yeah if you're not
complicit in the cancellation they can't
cancel you and right
what I think again opinion what I think
is occurring here is that the pendulum
swung so far cancellations uh wolf
culture all this stuff now it's swinging
back the risk is it swings so far back
that we go to the other end of the
extreme I don't think extremes on either
end are good right I actually think the
the kind of uh uh rational view of the
world of just like hey everyone chill
the [ __ ] out and like just go try to do
things that make you happy as long as
you're not hurting other people like
you're good right exactly
but the pendulum is swinging back and I
think what it does is actually a
confidence game because uh speaking of
Schultz when they came for Joe Rogan
Andrew Schultz I think was one of the
first if not the first person to be like
yo
all you people who are being quiet right
now like Joe Rogan's helped me in my
career Joe Rogan whatever he's like he
is not a racist
yeah which like was Blasphemous to the
people coming after Joe Rogan because
they were like obviously he is duh
didn't you see the video that they cut
out of thousands of interviews
and again whether you agree or not it
was like
if you objectively look at that
situation one person stood up and was
like no
and they say no another person's like no
no no no no and then it was like oh wait
it's mob versus mop yeah and so I think
that that is like a maybe it's not a
learned behavior as much as it's like
people now have a Playbook they see on
both sides the people attacking they
have a Playbook it's very well
understood now like pretty much if you
tell me a situation and you're like
they're gonna go after this person I can
tell you exactly how they're going to do
it yeah and the response seems to be
getting a Playbook
and so it's kind of like now we have
competing forces on the internet which
is kind of cool
it's entertaining for sure we're
definitely like leveling the playing
field because I think people just lived
in constant fear
of like oh God what if I what if I'm so
nobody's speaking their authentic truth
anymore yeah they're scared to get
canceled and the people who do just say
what they believe even if they're wrong
or right
they obviously get a following because
people are like oh that person isn't
scared and we were like oh I should
listen to what they have to say right
and so in some way uh I think the other
uh end of the extreme the people who
were
um doing a lot of the canceling I've
noticed that they seem a little deep
teeth now because there's been uh some
punches back it used to be just there's
one-way punches oh yeah and Society was
like very much the pendulum had swung
that way yeah totally now there's still
some people who like they love the fight
right and like they'll go on either side
yeah but there's a lot of people who are
like man this was a lot more fun when we
were doing the punching and there was no
one punching back and so like uh it's
fascinating to watch this because it
ends up being labeled I think kind of
culture wars or whatever and like at the
end of the day a lot of the [ __ ] doesn't
actually matter right like it doesn't
impact everyday people's lives and if uh
uh if you're deep down that rabbit hole
of watching a lot of this stuff like
damn do you got an easy ass life yeah
right like
but on the other hand
culture is what makes society and so
there's always been culture wars but
it's not been done on the internet you
know behind a keyboard and this weird
[ __ ] like cancellation platform yeah
but I think it's like you know you said
if we swing too far the other way we're
gonna go way back and kind of time but
those times are pretty good too
do you think it's good to swing all the
way back like no I don't think it'd be
extreme I think certain situations would
be more fun I think that it would be
more
it would be more fun to work on Wall
Street in like the 90s than today I feel
like today like who the heck wants to
work there I think that that is
objectively true yeah like I want
hookers and cocaine if I'm working on
Wall Street I want hookers and cocaine
if I can't get hookers and cocaine then
I don't why do I need to be there so
let's take that and kind of apply to a
couple different areas that really jump
to mind first
we live in a society that the War on
Drugs right War on Drugs uh that appears
I don't do cocaine I want to make sure
people know that
we're gonna cut that part out No One's
Gonna know uh
it appears that we are swinging back uh
Biden has this uh Federal uh kind of
mandate where he's at least saying hey
let's look at this maybe we need to
reclassify uh uh the scheduled drug like
all the stuff let's pardon people who
already uh went for simple possession
um
we're kind of returning pre-war on drugs
maybe not with the hard stuff but like
marijuana okay
then I do think that there's a lot of
people who whether it's through
Nostalgia or science data or just
frankly they're fed up with the current
[ __ ] or like man
the way the world was before all this
processed food that seems pretty good
100 yeah then I've seen like the memes
go around on the internet of like look
what they took from us on the airplane
right where it's like the two or three
people they're sitting there they're
getting like carved ham right there's
like not that many seats you're not
packed in like oh [ __ ] right yeah and
like they took this from us and so like
there's always going to be people who
look back to the past and they say to
themselves like
the better times are behind us but we do
can objectively look and like we live in
the safest most prosperous time in human
history today yeah uh do you believe the
future is going to be better or do you
think that actually there are things
from the past that we have to like
recreate again today in order to
continue to see progress this episode is
brought to you by eight sleep good sleep
is a game changer and the eight sleep
pod is the best sleep machine I sleep on
it every single night a great night of
sleep allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in each sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founder to let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep I mean I
think the future's gonna be better
because we're gonna have advancements in
medications and you know cures for
different things and but
it's not going to be better if we don't
get our [ __ ] together as Humanity what
do we have wrong Well everybody's
fighting they're not looking out for
each other they're sitting here saying
well the News tells me to hate you so
I'm gonna hate you this is what people
truly believe and so all of a sudden you
disagree with what they say and and
they're ignited with this hatred towards
you and then they want to cancel you so
to say right people need to realize that
like us together like Humanity needs to
band together and like not let the
government or the media dictate who they
can like and who they cannot like if we
don't fix that we're in trouble
but if we can fix that and enough people
say you know what
Barbara likes blue Becky likes pink who
gives a [ __ ]
they're both great people
they're children of God
move on is this what the future is going
to be much better is there somebody in
society that you point to and you're
like that person the way that they are
executing their strategy is like super
interesting I have one person in mind
but I want to hear who who you would say
first I'm trying to think of like just
somebody I have a lot of people you're
like that's like an independent thinker
that's somebody who who kind of walks to
their own uh to the beat of Their Own
Drum I think is a [ __ ] saying Elon
Musk right would come to mind so elon's
definitely won yeah is there anybody
else
foreign
's another one yeah yeah I was thinking
Kanye West oh yeah I feel I feel like he
gotten a little extreme lately but yeah
without a doubt he he is a human he
still has a you know
but I think that that's part of what
scares the [ __ ] out of society right is
like oh that guy actually you can't put
him in a box he's not left or right he's
not you know uh this or that like like
you don't know what he's gonna think
and he has a platform and so it's like
in some way
he's one of the purest independent
thinkers and again that doesn't mean I
agree with him on everything it just
means that like
if you can look at someone and say
there's a topic I know what you think
there's something that isn't independent
about the thought process well yeah it's
like they're controlled yeah it's
controlled but it's also just like like
the identity thing but it's a lot easier
to be truly truly authentic and say what
you want and not be in a box whatsoever
when you have enough money to survive
forever 1 000 right he he put himself in
a position to be able to do what he's
doing yeah but like if you went down I
don't know like all the uh topics that
uh get discussed in politics and you
went down I don't think most people
could guess with a high degree of
accuracy what Kanye West thinks about
each one of them
which is almost kind of how it should be
maybe yeah whereas like no that makes
sense if you look at other people and
and this happens on both sides of the
aisle uh but also even non you know uh
Republican or Democrat uh political
parties is I'll talk to friends and I'll
be like hey what do you think about this
and they'll somehow answer but it's like
Oh I'm a Republican and Republicans
think this right and so like my identity
tells me that this is how I'm supposed
to feel about it right that's the
problem yeah and so again politics is
the easiest one because it's like very
clear it's like red and blue and there's
a topic and this is how they each think
but this idea of like independent
thinking it scares the [ __ ] out of
society
because it is so rare
yeah but you know what's interesting
that I found is like I avoid politics
kind of at all cost Because unless
you're with a group that thinks exactly
like you unfortunately you're not
getting anywhere always changing your
mind you're not changing their mind
there's no need to argue about it you
avoid it right but
as soon as people start to say oh
if I don't agree with something so to
say I don't say oh it's because I'm a
Republican or oh it's because I'm a
Democrat I always say oh I'm in the
middle like I learned to think for
myself and I think both y'all are crazy
that actually from my experience
people just they they don't say anything
yeah they're like that makes sense it's
a way to just defuse the situation
because nobody's going to be like oh wow
you think for yourself and you're a
moderate and you think we're both yeah
she's right now if I had said oh let's
say a Democrat was yelling at he said oh
I'm a republican now you got an argument
yeah now they're coming at you bubba but
as soon as you say you're an independent
that's what I found
silence I don't even say it like I'm
legitimately an independent but the
thing I love to do uh I have friends
that are very extreme on both sides uh
and I always ask them I say can you tell
me one thing that you agree with the
other side on
and like and you watch just like smoke
come out of their ears right and like
brains are combusting but I do it in a
very loving way but I'm just like if you
tell me that there's zero things that
you agree with another person on
then like you are no longer thinking
like well you yeah I call like you're
just in the religion right like you
literally are just to a t in the
religion by the way it makes you happy
knock yourself out like who I don't give
a [ __ ] yeah totally like that is way
less intellectually interesting to me
than if you can sit there and say hey
this person that I have literally
appears nothing in common with I think
that this is right I think that's
interesting I see where they're coming
from on this other thing uh and then I
disagree on all these other things like
that to me is way more of a valuable
conversation and so well my wife hates
me in person too you know but I like to
bring them to the same dinner and then
like
you're very uh left-leaning like what
you think that Republicans write about
anything
and she's like oh Jesus
there and but what ends up happening is
if you can get the right people in that
conversation it's fascinating to see how
much they actually agree on the end
State it's the path to get to the end
state that they disagree on
right they want good things to happen I
don't know anyone on the Republican side
or the Democrat side that says we need
to pay more in taxes
even my friends that are so far left are
saying
milk's too high
groceries like everything's too high the
gas like I don't want my taxes to go up
but but we got to help these people I'm
like well who's gonna pay for it but I
want my taxes to go so it's like it's
the same everybody wants the same
everyone wants to feel safe and have the
government take less of their money
but they're not supporting the same
party that with the narrative they're
not like looking into the narrative to
be like oh this isn't going to work
maybe I should be
on the but hopefully in this in this
country we'll have a third party one day
do you think a third party is a solution
I don't know what the solution is I
think that's right I don't I have no
clue I think like bringing more faith
back into every day like offices and
schools and I think people have lost
their faith and they've lost kind of
empathy and being a good person and they
just
there's no consequences to being a
complete piece of [ __ ]
so I don't know what the exact solution
is I mean maybe Jesus will come back and
figure it out I don't know but I don't
know if there's a solution I had an
interesting conversation with a priest
friend of mine a priest a priest front I
have a friend I would love to hear this
and I said to him and I was just I think
I was watching the news I don't know I
just felt a little just not I wasn't
having like that great of a day and I
said do you think
the World's Gonna Get Better
or are we screwed
and he goes well according to the Bible
this is kind of how everything's
supposed to play out like
really not going to get that much better
like eventually it'll get better but
it's gonna get worse
before what's the Bible say well all
these different things need to happen
before he comes back
so there's gonna say Jesus is coming
back again more he was always planned
meant to come back
really yep he was always he's always
coming back damn my yeah Bible knowledge
is over decline
oh yeah there was always a second coming
you know I went I was supposed to plan
it I went and I checked to see if uh if
he was in the Tomb
wait of course he's not no I I was in
Israel and my brother
but uh we were there and uh and the tomb
were uh he allegedly Rose from yeah uh
we went there's a law I'm in line was
like insane right it's now like a Taurus
trap essentially yeah and uh and so we
went we looked in there and you know as
with many of these kind of historical
monuments like you go and it's almost
like the anticipation is more than you
look and you're like it's a tomb right
uh so it's not that much to see kind of
inside of it and then
uh we're like nope not there like like
positive right we checked yeah and the
people on the line you know you kind of
then look back and you're like oh these
people are gonna wait like three hours
to literally go see what we just saw and
like you ask yourself like
probably not waiting three hours without
the historical context the importance
like all the stuff it's more of like the
story and the historical stuff it makes
it what is worth waiting in line for I
would wait in line for that I I want to
say I haven't been there if you go just
go just go super early okay go super
early I just think it would be just such
a
few it you feel the gravity of the
situation yeah and just that like that
man Rose for us you know so we could so
wait hold on I'm letting you off the
hook [ __ ] what what is this he's coming
back thing well in the Bible the great
Revelations I think it was yeah he's
he's meant to come back and when he rose
he said I'll be back in two days and
each day was a thousand years so they're
estimating he died around 30 to 33. Okay
so
if he said you think Jesus is coming
back in a decade well you're not
supposed to guess or plan okay I can't
say that but am I prepared for the world
to go on forever absolutely oh am I
prepared if he came back tomorrow
absolutely when he comes back the world
ends
no they won't they won't end the
Believers will go they will rise they
won't die they will go with him
and then Satan is supposed to come down
and rule this place tribulation for
seven years it's gonna be bad you don't
want to get stuck here
and then he'll come back down and this
will kind of be Anew and he'll run this
place it'll be Heaven on Earth
essentially ah is the theory but you
can't plan for it
because it's not you're not just you're
just not supposed to do that so but I
always say I think you should be ready
for anything you should wake up ready
for the biggest day of your life whether
it's a business opportunity meeting your
special person
or Jesus coming back I think you should
be ready for everything if you met Jesus
in person what would you ask him
we're still why do you love us so much
why do you love us so much yeah so many
people have like just turned their backs
against him and just been terrible like
how can you love us so much
you know
and also like what's my purpose am I on
my purpose I think I'm living my purpose
but you always want to know if you could
have an opportunity to be like am I on
the right path is this the path for me
this may be the only thing that we're
going to disagree on today I don't think
I'd ask him any of that what would you
ask him how about you what's it like to
be Jesus Oh okay that's a good that'd be
fascinating right like hey man you you
never wake up and you're just like uh
I'm gonna [ __ ] some [ __ ] out today yeah
right you're never like hey you know
what uh I just like point and things
move like I know that's the stuff that
might be fascinating well here's another
question I'd ask him why are you letting
things
why are you letting the devil have so
much control why does it feel he has so
much control right now why why ha why
aren't people seeing the full truth of
what's really going on there's a purpose
there could be it could be him testing
us testing his people we have free will
you got to do the right thing so maybe
he's testing people
I uh the whole concept of the devil is
weird to me
like
when you really think about how it is uh
depicted
throughout history oh yeah
he's got like a little underground lair
his fire everywhere like it's kind of a
crazy
and I always uh uh I'm very interested
in uh the origination of like Concepts
it's like where did it come from and if
you think about
the devil the first person to be like
all right the concept of the devil let
me draw a fire and like all this stuff
and everything like that person who
actually took idea story you know
Constable stuff and put it into visual
form I mean they set for thousands of
years
the
the basic direction of the devil
but I think like I feel like he was a
fallen angel he was an angel but he was
fun I don't remember the exact story of
how he fell but he was a fallen angel
probably tripped on a stick right but
he's like a bad dude right I always say
sometimes they're frustrated I'm like
damn you Eve why'd you gotta eat that
apple look at all been running around
naked just living the dream and you had
to eat the apple and now we gotta deal
with this anchor on the news you you
were you were you were you were being uh
wait Kinder I was just thinking of like
Adam Sandler uh I think it's in the big
daddy where he just throws a stick in
front of the roller skater oh yeah right
like like that's the Fallen Angel yeah
exactly
I mean but here's the thing guys we all
do stupid [ __ ] we make mistakes it's
part of Being Human that's why you got
to forgive yourself and you got to
forgive others because God does the same
for us there's certain things obviously
you don't you just don't want to be a
piece of [ __ ] I honestly think
some of these people in Washington
and other places
I feel that they act as if they're going
to live forever
they are
if you're 78 years old 75 I don't know
how old uh uh Nancy Pelosi is but uh
she's 82. is she really
she's 80. she's in her 80s yeah
yo to be honest she's my financial
advisor
[Applause]
if I'm 82 and uh uh I can still
operate at all
kind of feel like she's winning
you may not agree with everything she
does may not think that maybe they
should be trading stocks and stuff but
like yeah
I if she retired do we think that uh
it'd be over pretty quick
oh like she didn't have a job anymore
well you know how they talk all the time
about like uh the people who work you
know relentlessly for decades and then
yeah and then they retire they have
nothing to do or like uh Mario Andretti
ever heard the story of him uh the race
car driver yeah he uh uh he drove fast
and the adrenaline would pump through
his body so much that when he stopped uh
driving that he went to the doctor and
the doctor was like all your organs are
failing and he was like what and he was
like uh your body thinks that you were
dying because he's not getting the
adrenaline it's used to on a consistent
basis
so can you go back and drive not really
I mean I think he probably did some
stuff they probably gave him some uh
treatments or whatever uh to try to
level out and you know tell about hey
you're not actually dying but like the
physiological you know kind of aspect of
uh being having a sustained level if all
of a sudden
she retires like that it's sad because
like people make it political in no way
uh should we politicize people's you
know lives like that but like
it ends up being the situation where uh
You can disagree with the ideas of
Someone You can disagree maybe even with
their intentions
but to some aspect like you gotta
respect
these people have done this for so long
yeah and like by the way the consistency
of doing wrong things just makes you
wrong right but like
there's not very many jobs that people
do for that long
it's kind of crazy it is I mean term
limits is what we definitely need but
she
hopefully she lives long but but you're
right when you lose your purpose
you can quickly your body can quickly
fall apart and you see it all the time
people retire they get bored and then
they just die I also think that
politicians I don't know if you've seen
Elon Musk uh he started now on the
earnings calls he'll take some questions
from YouTube
he'll find like a a Tesla uh Channel and
he'll like let them ask the question on
the earnings call and some of it is uh
him trying to like stick his middle
finger up basically to like the Wall
Street analyst who were you know saying
bad things for the company some of it is
actually like the questions are
incredibly intelligent so he's almost
saying like hey these people have
intelligent questions like let me talk
to them uh and then some of it is just
like he's Eli he's gonna do crazy things
and like how hilarious is it to be on
Ernie's call and take a question from
YouTube yeah totally imagine if the
politicians in the press conferences had
to always take two questions from the
from the internet
yeah it would completely change the
Dynamics of politics right it absolutely
was no one's safe all sides of the aisle
every press conference you gotta take
two questions from the internet and
they're voted on
I think it's brilliant because then you
would actually know what the people want
yes and by the way no they may be the
dumbest questions in the world but if
that's what the people want to ask you
work for the people so you gotta you
gotta answer the people yeah and so like
you know what I always thought with
politicians so if I if you're
interviewing me to work for this company
okay and I tell you I'm gonna do X Y and
Z and you hire me based on those
conditions because that's what you're
looking for and then I come in and I do
a b a b and c you're like but what about
XYZ I'm like well I'm just gonna do that
instead you would fire me
so we need to start holding the
politicians accountable if they run on
something and they don't accomplish it
they should be able to be fired so I
agree but what I would say uh and as
I've gone deeper down into some of these
rabbit holes understands those Works uh
I've changed my mind on a couple things
okay
um technically they can be fired which
is like the next election I think what
you're saying is like well maybe we
shouldn't wait four years or whatever
right
um but but that is technically I guess
how they could be fired the second thing
is uh
I agree if you say you're going to do a
and you don't do a that's a problem
it's a lot you ran on a lie well so
here's the caveat and I think where I've
probably maybe I've dulled the edges of
how I I uh view this is
I think that there are a lot of
situations where from the outside
they're essentially uneducated right
like they're like I'm gonna do a because
it sounds amazing it's like a stump
speech like all stuff and then they get
there and they realize like whoa if I do
a here's like the second and third order
effect of that that I didn't understand
previous or somebody shows up and
they're like hey by the way like cute
speech here's the actual way it works or
here's the information or whatever and
then they change their mind right
they're like oh you know what based on
the outside view like a seems like the
right thing but now that I have more
information like maybe B is the right
thing or a you know one is the right
thing and so
that shouldn't be an excuse for them to
be able to lie or to promise things and
then not do them but it is interesting
to think about like
if you say hey I'm gonna come work your
company I'm gonna do a b you know or XYZ
and then you show up and you're like oh
wait now that I see the data because I
don't think a lot of the candidates
actually get the information until they
get into office
oh okay that becomes interesting right
because now it's like oh wait a second
maybe the date is different but the
problem is they never say that they
never like hey I promised a but here's
the information that I saw I actually
don't think a is the right thing anymore
I now think B is the right thing let me
explain it to you let me take questions
well yeah and they don't do that because
nobody's held accountable
it feels like well how many people could
name you know how many if you went on
the street and you asked people name as
many politicians as you could think of
how many people could name 20 of them
probably not a lot I don't think that
many and by the way there's like a
thousand politicians maybe oh there's so
many right so like if you can't name
20.
out of a thousand you don't care right
you're not paying attention it's like
kind of the way I think about you you
just it it you don't have to say what
their policies are whether you can't say
their names then like okay you're just
not paying attention right which is a
proxy for you don't care yeah
and I think regardless of what people
want
who's gonna like you're just not gonna
change people's mind like humans are
humans what do they want to do like
people are doing drugs in their ways
yeah yeah for sure so that's why like I
don't I don't try to change people's
minds I'm just like okay here's the
information do with it as you wish yeah
I just like the [ __ ] on the internet
exactly just sit here and do this I
don't think I've ever like said
something mean on me I'm just not a mean
person
my brothers all the time well that's
normal my brother beat the [ __ ] out of
me when I was little do you know it's in
I actually talk about it in the book
it's funny because there's actually
something that's no longer true in that
book
so when I was little my brother and his
cousin or my cousin they were the same
age they used to get me to do everything
for them go get a sodas go get us candy
go get us towels go do all in the
promise that I would receive a farting
bear well farting bear farty I just
wanted a teddy bear that farted that's
all I wanted it's my dream thing I never
got the Ted the the farting bear
until my birthday this year so my
brother and his wife went to build a
bear
and got me a farting bear now
Build-A-Bear doesn't make farting Bears
my brother bought the recorder
took it home ate a [ __ ] ton of beans
farted in it went back to build a bear
shoved it in a bear and now I've got
this farting bear what was your reaction
when he gave it to you
oh I laughed so hard because I couldn't
believe it was actually his fart in the
bear
but I thought like this is it was
actually an amazing present
like so now I it sits on my shelf but it
was like such a such a formative you
know
thing but it's like I got so toughened
up you may not always get what you want
but you get what you need
which for me was to be very tough
because I my brother definitely treated
me like I was a little boy I've never
done this in a conversation on the show
before but I think that this is uh
interesting the names of the chapters in
your book
time to find Financial Freedom time to
stop being afraid time to step into
Faith time to create your new amazing
reality time to believe in yourself time
to escape the tunnel time to stop being
offended time to improve your
relationship time to get out of your own
way
it's pretty interesting because
while the book is funny while the book
is your life in reality this book is a
pretty quick read to get quite a bit of
value out of hey if you're sitting in
whatever position in life and you're
just like is this it is this really what
I want to be doing
I think that reading certain books yeah
are important reading certain books at
certain points in time
is where like the real magic is and so
there's uh the Collision of ideas and
like the time in your life
it feels like for those people who are
stuck pretty good uh pretty good one to
pick up oh yeah and I give a lot of uh
real world examples of how I was living
in the scarcity mindset and how I
overcame it also like you know with
faith and using the law of attraction
that kind of helps you in your mindsets
and your thoughts create your reality
all these things that kind of I woke up
to but it's very unfiltered I didn't
want a filtered book that was just
talking at you there's a lot of like
naughty jokes in there that that were
just real I mean I want you to read you
do me a favor
let me find a free I want you to should
we just read the whole book here no I
want you to read page page eight
starting with the second paragraph
where it says you were just young and I
want you to read I see three words I'm
like oh boy and the next one
you're on
I don't think I could read this and not
get us kicked off YouTube You Were Young
just yesterday wasn't it fresh out of
college and bright-eyed and full of
plans you were gonna change the world
get rich get laid and or married and
have it all that meant making a name for
yourself finding something to call
happiness proving anyone who ever
doubted you wrong but more and more the
days go on without the boom ever coming
and [ __ ] is so much harder and so much
less satisfying than you thought it
would be life feels like a frat party
where you're sucking everyone
just so you'll get invited back next
time problem is every time it's the same
sausage fest like what's the solution
where's the doorway and what's the
secret sauce do you have an audiobook
because if not I might be for hire I
think I might have to hire you I don't
have one yet but I think it would be
great you just can't censor the keywords
yeah well uh you could thank uh Susan
from YouTube She uh she doesn't like
when we say that word oh that's
hilarious yeah she is not as funny uh
who's Susan from YouTube uh see you oh
does she actually censor the D the
d-i-c-k word I said it um I'm sure that
she probably does I don't know she's
taking videos down with her Channel
deleted at one point you know I gotta
love hate relationship sometimes she
sends videos viral though so hey you
can't hate her I think we were pretty
clean on this side I thought so too
where can people go find the books so
they can go to Amazon or Barnes
noble.com right now eventually it'll be
in all the stores should be in Barnes
Noble soon and um yeah they can order it
online and then um I also have a podcast
that you have been on next to Madison
so I'll be uh talking more about that
book on that podcast as well
what about social media where can we
send people to find uh my Instagram is
at real Madison Malloy and then other
Traders huh are there fake ones you know
my original one got hacked and it was so
I took my podcast one originally and
then I'm like so Madison Malloy wasn't
available because
it got hacked because I had to do real
mad assembly I'm like yeah I guess I'm
real Madison boy it'd be funny if I was
fake what about Twitter and then Madison
Malloy and then I have a tick tock
Channel but only because I have to are
you big on Tick Tock no oh I'm big on
Tick Tock but maybe I'll get big on Tick
Tock how many do you have you're huge on
we got we got videos how many videos we
got we got one with a million views yeah
yeah we got a million views last week
did you yeah I don't know if that's
actually good or not I have no clue I've
never even been on time I think that
somebody else uploads the videos but
they said we're big we're big on Tick
Tock yeah which by the way is my theory
on Tick Tock as most of the people who
are big on Tick Tock that are like a
little bit older they're not actually
the ones on Tick Tock it's just people
uploading the videos from uh Instagram
or YouTube yeah I'm big with the kids I
feel like you gotta just you have to go
on it you know what Tick Tock is a
grandfather saying that I feel like
actually if you you start looking at
certain things you start searching
certainly no I can't get on great
information they know I can't do it why
can't help China and I feel like I'll
get addicted I feel like I'll get it you
will get addicted I have profits on
there that come up in my algorithm
doctors about supplements
um side hustles wait real quick because
you told me you're taking a supplement
that uh is like a wonder drug yeah not
medical advice this is not right if you
go to uh Tick Tock and you literally
type in NAC NAC Nancy Apple Charlie yep
um
it's like the longevity thing the whole
like all the the videos and the comments
this thing like helps fight free radical
damage so when you travel on an airplane
you should double up on it the day
before and the day after right because
when you're in Flight in the
stratosphere free radical damage is
higher did you know that your taste buds
change in uh in there
no that's why they changed the uh the
type of food that they serve I know
interesting is that why everything's so
salty yes yeah and also why a lot of
people uh order tomato juice supposedly
he's kind of like sleeping at uh what
are the Hampton Inn or whatever yeah
yeah no but I actually dude flight
attendants need to take this I I was on
a flight and I told people about this
but I'm telling you and it's a woman
it's called NEC a skincare woman told me
to take this so she's like doing a
facial for me and I started taking this
thing
I can't I won't live without it there's
the reason the FDA is trying to ban it
you can't find it on Amazon oh FDA is uh
because they want to make it
prescription because this stuff is so
good you can get like 250 for like 19.99
okay I am never tired
never sick the only reason I caught a
little cold last week is because I
forgot to take it for like five days
this thing makes your immune system
so Rock Solid I feel like I could lick a
Subway pole and nothing would happen to
me it's given me like dynamite and then
I was on Tick Tock and I saw this other
guy come on he goes there was a study
out of Baylor University that
they might have cracked like the
Fountain of Youth is what he was saying
he goes these two supplements over the
counter taken together
could be the fountain what's the second
one NAC was one and the other one was
glycine glycine it sounds like some
Clorox [ __ ] yeah so you take those
together so I'm gonna go and pick up
some glycine glycine yep not medical
advice right no it's not medical advice
it's all natural what is glycine I don't
know exactly what it is I have to do but
it's another yeah
it is don't look at what it is just take
a bunch of it like over the next couple
of weeks and then just see like what
happens and then look to see what you
were taking it's kind of like you ever
gone to a restaurant they're like no
they've got like some uh no they got
like some like fancy looking name or
whatever and then you know my thing is
they usually turn people away what is
this what like what's that mean and
they're like oh it's like a liver or
heart or whatever
uh I'm gonna just get the burger yeah
right exactly but no it's supposed to be
amazing all right NAC and glycine yeah
I'm gonna go do research but the NAC
thing I mean I swear by that and I'm not
like a big like supplement like I take
what I need to think but this is the one
that I only take one thing every day
well two things actually uh no three
things actually uh
yeah just three things uh are you sure
yeah emergency I'll put a little thing
powder because I kind of feel like a
scientist when I'm making it and then I
get a drink is supposed to be good for
you uh two is uh athletic greens I'm
like obsessed yeah I heard that's right
uh yeah the uh ag-1 I'm so obsessed that
they advertise with us I'm an investor
in the business and if I could figure
out how to take the powder and have it
be made into like food so that I could
eat also and get and feel like I'm
getting the same thing I'll do that yeah
and then the uh the third one is uh uh
the equivalent of like the Flintstone
gummy Uh like multivitamin okay I don't
think it actually does anything I just
like the idea of you know like I took a
little thing I uh every day and you're
supposed to like get all the vitamins
can you do you can do the gummy ones
yeah I like those much better I can't do
the gummy ones you wanna know why why
I'll eat the whole [ __ ] bottle yeah
very good oh I'd get those vitamin C
ones and I'm like now the the emergency
is like on unlock I think anyone who's
ever lived in New York or New Jersey or
anywhere like in the Northeast during
the winter you take two of emergencies
every day and you're golden every day
how many milligrams you're not supposed
to do that not financially or not
Financial or medical advice uh I think
you're supposed to take One A Day well
how many if I double up how many
milligrams of Vitamin C is actually no
clue because they say You're supposed to
get around a thousand milligrams of
Vitamin C a day but you can't take it
you can't go to the store and buy a
thousand milligrams because you can all
your body can only process 500 at a time
so you should take one in the morning
and then one see that's what I used to
do it I think I used to take one in the
morning one at night and then I was like
well why am I doing that I want to take
them both together well maybe I'm doing
it wrong well because you're you're just
gonna pee it out it's not going to cause
you any damage so you're just basically
peeing away your money my parents take
more vitamins than anyone I know I
literally they got vitamins for the
morning the afternoon the night I mean
pounds of pills you should replace them
all with just like uh uh Placebo pills
and see if they notice I know all right
don't do that if they have medical
conditions yeah they're not on
medications like all their friends
except like you know oh so they're not
medically yeah they're just like
vitamins they're just vitamins they're
so healthy but they're not on you know
high cholesterol and all these other
drugs that people in their 70s typically
are on they're not on them but I think
it's a little bit of an overload so my
sister-in-law oh my sister-in-law we
always joke that we're like they have
the most expensive piss on the Block you
know what I'm saying because they're
just big because you just get rid of
them the fish oil is the one I got a lot
of friends they take the fish oil yes
and flaxseed oil is really good for your
skin I haven't been taking that that
reminds me I gotta get it yeah that
sounds weird I'm out well there was this
one guy I knew College used to work I
had that you put in your drinks I need
to do that yeah it tastes like chalk on
I'm out I know but if it makes your skin
look better I'd like to get those huge
like deep like radio frequency things
that just like Hydra facial my friend is
the chairman of a a company that owns
hydrafacial that's a good one but it
doesn't provide the results that you
need like I like the no I mean it does
it looks you look great for an event
right but if you really want like you
need the Morpheus or the CO2 like the
ones where you're crying basically and
yeah somebody's pressure washing your
face yeah then that's like the good
stuff yeah it's gonna get you this stuff
but I do like the Hydra facial I do like
it I'm just saying like if I want some
lifting and tightening you got to go for
the laser can I leave you with one
absolutely insane uh fact that you're
gonna like be like I cannot believe that
uh one that's true or two you're
admitting it publicly what I was 27
years old I think when I met Paulina
okay and I one day we were talking and
she said something and I was like and
you know like when somebody says
something and you're like oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna have to admit something and I know
it's not gonna be well received yeah I
had that moment and then she like was
like what and I was like nothing
she was like what and I was like uh I
figured like I should just tell you this
now uh I've never watched my face before
and she was like what do you mean and I
was like
yeah like the only time I've ever washed
my face was like with a bar of soap
oh like and yeah in the shower like in
the shower yeah but like I like face
wash she was like talking about I was
like
I grew up in a house with five boys like
that wasn't a thing like we didn't have
any of that stuff yeah and uh and she
was like that's disgusting and so now
fast forward five six years whatever it
is like uh what are they called face
masks yeah
yeah every guy I know doesn't none of
them like talk about them so uh the
sheet mask or like the actual like Mass
no like the scrub stuff like uh or like
the you know it's kind of like a lotion
or whatever but then it's hard on their
faces yeah they all do this [ __ ] but now
I'm like talking about men's beauty is
on through the roof I like to wait till
we're all at dinner with and like you
know everyone's like girlfriends wise
whatever they're gonna be like so guys
what's the uh what's the latest face
mask you all using yeah everyone gets
real quick everyone's like hey [ __ ] I
ain't gonna admit that and immediately
the other people are like oh he likes
this one or he likes this one
gets them every time all right oh that's
great time to lighten the [ __ ] up a
self-help guide with a side of humor I
appreciate it very much thank you thank
you everyone go get the book if you
don't get the book then you just don't
have a good sense of humor so yeah buy
the book we'll do it again in the future
perfect thank you so much